LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to "Coffee with a Googler"
from New York City.
I'm Laurence Moroney.
On a previous episode,
we met with Ray Tsang
from the Google
Cloud Platform team.
But one of the things that we
didn't cover in that episode
was looking at the back end
of how all of this is done.
So today I'm meeting with
Francesc Campoy who was one
of the developers on the team.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Fransesc, welcome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, hi.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So that seemed
like a really cool project
to work on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It was definitely
one of the coolest
project I've worked at,
for a very long time, yes.
Lots of fun.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It
certainly looked like it.
Now, when we met
with Ray, we were
talking about how the
pictures were taken-- well,
the videos were taken
with an audio cue in them,
and then they were
uploaded to the cloud.
But what happened next?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
basically once the phones get
to upload those files to the
Google Cloud Storage what
we have is we've set what we
call object modifications,
or back end modifications.
So basically, we will
receive some HTTP request,
and you get to choose where
that HTTP request is sent.
So we are actually processing
those with [INAUDIBLE],
and basically, what we say is,
as soon as that file has been
received, we will
just record that
and we'll put it into a queue.
It actually pops up.
So that way, we're able to say,
oh, we have to handle this.
For now, we don't handle it.
We just say, we
have to handle that,
so we just put it in the queue.
And then what we
do is then we'll
have a different process, which
is what we call the extractors,
and an extractor is actually
just a very simple Python
script that uses MoviePy
which is this library.
It's just an easy
way of using FFmpeg.
FFmpeg is an amazing
library, but it's
quite complicated to use.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes, it is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So with MoviePy,
it just makes it that much
easier, and what we do
is we just go and find
that single frame.
There's that noisy
frame, that's when you
press that little button there.
It's like, beep.
We extract that single frame,
and we put that frame back
into the Google Cloud Storage.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now we have
a video of all this in action,
so why don't we
take a look at it.
-One, two, three, go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRENT MCGOWEN: So
right now, every camera
is uploading its video
to Google Cloud Storage,
and you can see in the process,
here it is in the input bucket.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Hey, how's it looking?
BRENT MCGOWEN:
Yeah, he wrote most
of the code to do all this.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
bet he did it in Go.
BRENT MCGOWEN: He
did in Go, as you can
see our little gopher up here.
So what's happening
in the cloud right
now is our extractors are
going to look into each video,
and it's going to try and find
a frame that has that audio beep
to mark the same moment in time.
Now once we have all the frames
extracted from all the videos,
it'll put it into
our stitcher process
in the cloud, which is
on a Compute Engine.
It'll save it to the output
bucket and Google Cloud Storage
and it'll show it to you.
[LAUGHING]
BRENT MCGOWEN: It's pretty cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's pretty cool.
I like the finger.
So I can now post that to
Twitter and G+ and stuff like
that?
BRENT MCGOWEN: Yeah, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, cool.
I'm going to do it right now.
And here it is from--
@googlecloudspin
have tweeted me, and I'm going
to favorite and re-tweet that.
Bing, done.
Now I could understand
like having-- in this case,
it was 19 videos.
These 19 videos
uploaded, and all these
processes that need to be kicked
off on them-- that there's
a synchronization problem there,
so how did you solve that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so that's actually partly
why we use Pub/Sub.
So with Pub/Sub, it
allows us to decouple
how many machines are behind.
So rather than processing one
single file at a time, what
we can do is-- if we
have 19 videos, then
we can 19 extractors.
So we're making it
as a parallel job.
And then the problem
is that well, if you
have 19 things happening
at the same time,
when are you actually done?
And that's the hard
part, so synchronizing
all of those things
and making sure
that we have all the frames
before we stitch them together.
And that's actually done,
again with Firebase.
So we're using Firebase
basically a little
bit everywhere.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, because Ray
was talking about that it
was used as a remote control
effectively for starting
the videos being shot,
and now you're using
it for synchronizing
the grabbing in the frames?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and actually, we also
use it even to be
able to visualize
the status of the whole system.
So we're able to see,
where are those frames?
Did we extract them already?
Are we done stitching
everything together?
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, nice.
Now, so one of the
things-- once you've
extracted each of these
frames, now these frames
have to be stitched together
to make it animated GIF, right?
So how did you do that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So again, what we
do is every single time
we're done extracting one
single frame, we put a
new task into Pub/Sub,
and then that Pub/Sub is
received by the stitcher,
we call it, which is just a very
simple program written in Go.
Of course.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I was wondering,
because people who are watching
this who would know Francesc,
would be saying, didn't
he say Python earlier?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I know.
I know.
LAURENCE MORONEY: But
you did this part in Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, there
was no a good port or binding
for FFmpeg with Go, so that's--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Tell
me you're working on it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
actually working on it.
[LAUGHING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's kind
of a really huge project,
so it will take
time, but I think
it's worth doing, especially
for these kind of demos.
I mean, it's a fun
demo, so why not?
So yeah, that
stitcher, what it does
is every single time it
receives an notification saying,
oh, this frame is
ready, it checks this.
Yeah, this frame is ready, but
are all the other ones also
ready?
And that's actually done on
checking Firebase continuously.
Once they are what
ready, what will happen
is that the stitcher will
download all of those frames
from the Google
Cloud Storage bucket,
and stitch them all together
into one single GIF.
And then put it back into
Google Cloud Storage.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
So I'm hearing there's so many
elements of the Cloud Platform
being used here,
for Compute Engine.
You've used App Engine.
You use Cloud Storage.
You use Pub/Sub.
This is a really nice way
of stretching and showing
people how the different
elements of the Cloud Platform
can work together,
because sometimes that
can be confusing to
[? different people. ?]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that was a little bit
the goal of the thing.
It was basically, what can
we do with the Google Cloud
Platform that will
show the power of it,
but at the same
time will be fun?
So people will get
interested into it
and say, how does
this actually work?
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
now if a developer
wants to learn how you did
what you did, what can they do?
Is there a blog post or
documentation or anything
that's--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There
is not one blog post.
There's actually three of them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Three?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So good,
you did it three times.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So yeah, there's going to be
one talking about a little bit
the whole project,
how it was created.
One describes more the Android
part, and then the third one,
which is more about this cloud
part of how is this, everything
[? on ?] in the back end.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And for folks who'd
be interested in how you
used FFmpeg or the Go stuff
that you wrote, are you making
that source code available?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, yeah, that
will be open source
quite soon, we hope.
We're just removing
some hacks and things
that we had to do for the demos.
LAURENCE MORONEY: The
usual things people
have to do before
they open source code.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, exactly.
It's a demo.
It has to run, even if the
code is not perfect, so yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And that
will be announced on the blog
as well, when that's available?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that will be on the blog.
Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So developers,
keep an eye on the Google Cloud
Platform blog.
So thank you, Francesc.
That was awesome.
And I've learned so much,
and I had so much fun
actually playing with the demo
and doing my own Cloud Spin.
So if you want to learn how
to do this for yourself,
take a look at the blog post
that Francesc mentioned,
there on the Google
Cloud developers' blog.
Also, when the source
code is available,
it will be announced there.
If you've any questions
for me or if you've
any questions for
Fransesc, just please
leave them in the
comments below,
and tune into the Google
Developers channel
for more great videos,
including more episodes
of "Coffee with a Googler,"
and the one that we
had with the rest of
the Cloud Spin team.
So thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]